2026년 5월 1일 금요일 미국 증시 요약입니다.
금요일 미국 증시는 상승 마감했습니다.
이란 전쟁 종시에 대한 기대가 커지면서
S&P 500 지수는 5주 연속 상승하며
2024년 이후 가장 긴 주간 랠리를 이어갔습니다.
종목별로 살펴보면 애플은 호실적에 힘입어 3.2% 상승하며
지난 2월 이후 최대 상승폭을 기록했습니다.
메모리 반도체 관련 주인 샌디스크가 8% 급등한 반면
웨스턴 디지털은 실적의 예상치를 웃돌았음에도 불구하고
한층 높아진 시장의 기대치를 충족시켜주지 못해
주가가 하락하는 대주적인 모습을 보였습니다.
오라클은 미 국방부의 이밀 네트워크 구축에 참여하는
AR 기업 명단에 공식 합류하기로 합의하면서 6.5% 급등했습니다.
반면 로블럭스는 주 사용층인 어린이들의 플랫폼 이용을 제한하는
안전기능을 도입한 여파로 이상보다 부진한 사용자 수를 발표하며
18% 폭락했습니다.
한편 이란이 미국 측에 새로운 제안을 전달했다는 소식이 전해지며
유가는 배럴단 102달러 선으로 떨어졌습니다.
다만 트럼프 대통령은 이란이 합의를 요구하고는 있지만
자신은 현재 상황에 만족하지 않는다고 밝혔습니다.
이란이 수용할 수 없는 조건들을 요구하고 있다고 지적하면서도
이란을 직접 타격하는 것은 원치 않는다고 덧붙였습니다.
아울러 트럼프 대통령은 유럽연합산 자동차와
트럼프에 부과하는 관세를 25%로 인상하겠다고 밝혀
무역정책을 둘러싼 긴장감도 한층 부각됐습니다.
그럼에도 불구하고 전쟁이 초래할 수 있는
경제적 파장에 대한 시장의 우려는 한층 누그러진 모습입니다.
기업들의 견주한 실적이 랠리에 불을 지피면서
증시는 2020년 이후 최고의 월간 상승을 기록했습니다.
실제로 블룸버그 집계에 따르면
S&P500 기업의 약 81%가 1분기 실적 전망치에
상해했습니다.
이제 시장의 시선은 다음주에 발표될 AMD와
팔런티의 실적으로 쏠릴 전망입니다.
시장 참가자들은 경제 지표에도 주목했습니다.
전쟁으로 인해 투입 물가가 급등했음에도 불구하고
제조 확장세는 견주하게 이어진 것으로 나타났습니다.
한편 지난 FOMC 회의에서 반대표를 던진 3명의 여는 총재들은
시장에 계속해서 금리 인하 신호를 주는 것이
더 이상 적절하지 않다며 반대의 이유를 밝혔습니다.
미네폴리스 연원의 카시카리 총재는
FOMC는 향후 금리가 인하될 수도, 인상될 수도 있다는
정책 전망을 제시해야 한다고 강조했습니다.
클리브랜드 연원의 헬멕 총재는
유가 상승이 물가 상승 압력을 가중시키고 있다고 지적했으며
달러스 연원의 로건 총재는
인플레이션이 목표치로 회복되기까지
얼마나 오랜 시간이 걸릴지에 대해 우려를 표했습니다.
UBS의 울리케 오프만은
실적과 향후 금리 인하가 인상될 수도 있다고 강조했습니다.
향후 가이던스가 모두 양호했다.
기술주가 상승을 주도하고 있지만
견주한 소비지출과 경기 순화적 상승 신호에 힘입어
실적 성장세가 폭넓게 확산되고 있다.
카슨그룹의 라이언 디트릭은
실적 시즌이 예상보다 강하게 이어지는 가운데
S&P 500 지수는 1950년 이후 두 번째로 좋은 4월을 기록했다.
이러한 상승 모멘텀은 5월에도 충분히 이어질 수 있을 것으로 보인다.
라고 전하였습니다.